après avoir passé la moitié de sa vie
derrière les barreaux son père va être
libéré une sortie qui inspire des
sentiments contradictoires à la fillette
[Musique]
leur nom de famille a défrayé la
chronique il s'est étalé dans les
journaux pendant des années à la
rubrique fait divers et pourtant ils
sont innocents
Michael et Sarah sont les enfants de
deux anciens ennemis publics le matin
leur papa n'allait ni au bureau ni à
l'usine l'un par tes braquer les banques
l'autre régnait sur les jeux et la
prostitution si Michael était au courant
de ce que faisait son père
Sarah elle n'a appris que plus tard
malgré une enfance hors norme il partage
des points communs avec nous tous les
non-dits le silence les secrets de
famille et notre milieu qui n'est pas
une fatalité
je m'appelle Zem mon père s'appelait
Edgar themon figure du grand banc de
tisme
je suis Sarah Bauer j'ai 35 ans je suis
la fille de Charlie Bauer une des
figures du grand banditisme a priori
tout oppose aujourd'hui ce célibataire
solitaire et cette jeune mère de famille
pourtant l'un comme l'autre ont un nom
et un héritage très lourd à porté durant
des années leur père ont fait la une des
journaux et alimenter la rubrique des
faits divers ce sont des enfants de
figures du grand banditisme de parcours
d'adultes qui ont dû apprendre à se
construire avec le poids du passé
[Musique]
c'est à Paris que Michael Zemmour
passent les premières années de son
enfance
ces grands boulevards il les connaît par
cœur pour les avoir arpentés
quotidiennement avec son père Edgar un
quartier ou pour l'enfant tout est
permis
et pour cause ici dans les années 60
Edgar Zemmour et ses trois frères font
régner leur loi ils ont près de 400
hommes sous leurs ordres et sont les
maîtres de la pègre parisienne
prostitution cabaret contrebande
raquette dans la capitale aucune
activité criminelle n'échappe au
contrôle du clan Z
et c'est ici boulevard Montmartre que le
père de Michael gérer ses affaires
[Musique]
à la fenêtre qui surveillait ici à
l'extérieur pour savoir qui c'est qui
arrivait sa voiture est-ce qu'il y avait
des mecs qui guettaient il se passe et
toutes ces choses là et
bah ça faisait partie du ça
le cercle c'était à l'époque le royaume
des jeux d'argent derrière les fenêtres
anonymes de l'immeuble ont joué des
millions de francs chaque semaine un
marché juteux
et mais pour le petit garçon de 4 ans
qui était zèbre le cercle c'était juste
un formidable terrain de jeu
[Musique]
freiner à cette fenêtre là
toute la journée pratiquement dans les
touristes venaient pour faire la queue
devant le musée Grévin je leur jeter des
pétards je trouvais ça assez drôle et
alors il y en avait qui rentrait qui
perdait 20000 francs 30 000 francs
100.000 francs il partait énervé et moi
je dois retirer dessus avec mon pistolet
à plomb
sans me rendre compte de l'ampleur des
choses quoi
l'enfant bénéficier de l'aura du clan
Zemmour les commerçants ne lui
refusaient rien rue du Faubourg
Montmartre ont respecté les frères
Zemmour et ont choyé le petit Michael
tout le quartier était devenu pour moi
un espèce de terrain de jeu je pouvais
aller un peu n'importe où dans tous les
troquets dans tous les cafés je paye
rien j'ai le droit de boire des coca
manger faire ce que je voulais et il me
disait c'est bien c'est pas grave même
d'ailleurs quand je me balade dans le
dans le quartier des fois il y avait des
gens qui m'appelaient pour me donner des
choses donc je comprenais pas trop mais
bon j'en profitais en même temps
pour Zem poussez la porte de cet
immeuble c'est faire remonter des
souvenirs vieux de plus de 30 ans
quand tu rentrais souvent tu pouvais
entendre les joueurs en haut et les
cafés qui tournaient les mecs qui
gueulaient non c'est pas toi c'est moi
tout le monde connaissait la famille et
j'avais le droit de j'avais le droit de
tout faire à rien mettez interdit il y a
une nostalgie ici qui est qui est
palpable pour moi et en haut de ces
quelques marches j'aime se retrouvent
face à face avec son passé
il est toujours là
[Musique]
je crois même pas qu'ils ont changé la
porte et puis
[Musique]
non et la sonnerie elle est là
j'ouvre la fenêtre en fait
j'ouvre la fenêtre il y a toujours pas
de cadenas ici là
donc je passais par là
la deuxième fenêtre elle donnait dans le
bureau de mon père donc une fois quand
il faisait des affaires ou quand il
mettait de l'argent dans le coffre ou
quand il avait des discussions avec des
mecs j'allais me mettre à la fenêtres
pour regarder ce qu'il faisait puisqu'il
disait souvent la fenêtre était fermée
donc j'entendais pas mais je les voyais
je le voyais mettez de l'argent dans le
coffre et de l'argent
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression qu'il est là
c'est dur c'est dur
c'est
ça a été bien ça il y a eu des choses
magiques mais il y a beaucoup de choses
très très tragique des événements
dramatiques l'histoire de la famille de
Michael en est jalonné le 28 février
1975 William son oncle les tabattus par
les policiers de l'antigang lors d'une
fusillade dans une brasserie parisienne
Edgar son père et grièvement blessé pour
le clan menacé il est grand temps de
quitter Paris direction Miami
[Musique]
Michel Marie vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste des faits divers vous avez
couvert plus d'un millier de procès en
35 ans et côtoyer autant d'accusés ça
ressemble à quoi le milieu du grand
banditisme dans les années 70 alors le
grand banditisme dans les années 70
c'était des bandes organisés
structurés ou chacun avait son rôle un
peu comme dans une entreprise comme dans
une société c'était des PME et ça
fonctionnait autour évidemment de crimes
et délice c'était essentiellement des
braquages de banque c'était le gang des
postiches par exemple qui ont fait je ne
sais combien de centaines de braquages
en quelques années c'était très
populaire à l'époque c'était sa
fascinait
quand on connaît l'histoire de Mesrine
quand on a vu ce film quand on a lu son
ou ses bouquins je crois qu'on peut être
que fasciné ce qu'il a fait tout au long
de sa vie n'est pas bien c'est
répréhensible c'est punissable d'accord
mais ce type là avec quelque chose de
sympathique moi j'ai le souvenir de de
Mesrine lorsqu'il se fait arrêter avant
d'être tué ou Broussard tape à la porte
en disant salut c'est Brossard et
l'autre lui dit ah bah si c'est toi je
t'ouvre et
il se rend à Broussard il y a pas eu un
coup de feu de tirer il lui offert le
champagne ça vous le verrez plus jamais
est-ce que ça existe encore aujourd'hui
les grandes familles de bandit
il y a des grandes familles de bandits
sauf que c'est complètement déstructuré
je pense en particulier à Marseille ou
certaines cités de banlieue parisienne
tout ça un peu volé en éclat à
l'époque on peut dire qu'il y avait un
code d'honneur enfin en tout cas les
types qui montaient sur ces braquages
n'auraient pas comme une meurtre de
façon gratuite j'ai un peu le sentiment
à cette époque là que si je m'étais
trouvé dans la banque au moment d'un
braquage du gang des postiches il ne
m'aurait rien fait alors qu'aujourd'hui
j'aimerais pas me retrouver dans une
banque au moment d'un braquage
[Musique]
les émours sont exilés aux États-Unis et
c'est sous le soleil de Floride que va
débuter une longue descente aux enfers
pour Mickaël
[Musique]
Sarah Bauer est une maman de 35 ans qui
vit au cœur du Loiret elle est
aujourd'hui principale adjointe dans un
collège de la région une carrière
professionnelle et une vie familiale
épanouie pour cette jeune femme qui a
pourtant connu une enfance compliquée
sarah est la fille de Charlie Bauer l'un
des détenus les plus médiatiques de
France c'est à Marseille sa ville natale
que le jeune Bauer débute sa carrière
criminelle en multipliant les
cambriolages arrêtez en 1962 il prend
une peine de 20 ans rébellion tentative
d'évasion il est placé en quartier de
haute sécurité et connaît l'enfer de
l'isolement
libérer en 1977 Charlie Bauer rencontre
Jacques Mesrine l'ennemi public numéro 1
les deux hommes montent des coûts
braquent des banques mais leur
collaboration est de courte durée en
1979 Mesrine est abattu par la police
pour Charlie Bauer c'est retour à la
case prison 9 années durant lesquelles
il passe deux licences et un doctorat
libéré en 1998 après avoir passé plus de
la moitié de sa vie derrière les
barreaux la légende du banditisme
devient écrivain et donne des
conférences sur les prisons
nous sommes en 1979 Charlie Bauer et sa
femme sont incarcérées Sarah n'a que
deux ans quand Jacques Mesrine a été a
été exécutée donc après mon mes parents
ont été arrêtés les deux
bon ma mère a été complètement innocenté
de tout mais elle a pas été là pendant
un certain temps et du coup elle m'a
confié à son père à sa mère donc à mon
grand-père et ma grand-mère qui m'ont
qui m'ont pris en charge j'étais toute
petite toute petite ma maman manquait ça
c'est sûr
maintenant ça c'est je pense que c'est
des choses qui étaient difficiles mais
j'étais trop petite pour m'en souvenir
aujourd'hui
et puis bah quand ma maman est revenu
les choses sont redevenues pour moi
complètement normal même si derrière il
y avait une situation très très dure et
très très difficile à vivre pour pour
une enfant de 18 mois
son père c'est au parois de la prison
qu'elle va faire sa connaissance la
première visite en prison je m'en
souviens pas mais je pense que j'avais
peut-être 4 ans et demi quatre ans et
demi cinq ans voilà et donc ça c'était
pas très très bien passé pour moi
c'était un inconnu donc voilà c'était
pas évident au début
petite je réclamais pas du tout
ce père
aujourd'hui Sarah ne garde de ses
visites en prison que des images
oppressantes je me souviens de toutes
les portes qui souffrent qui se ferment
qui souffrent qui se ferme dans tous les
sens qui les gardiens sous la grosse
porte grise du début où il y a un
gardien qui ouvre la salle d'attente qui
est pas très jolie les salles de parloir
qui sont pas très belles non plus la foi
où il avait dû se passer forcément
quelque chose puisqu'il était derrière
une vitre ça ça m'a un peu un peu
choquée
un univers carcéral froid et déshumanisé
qui ne facilitent pas le contact entre
la petite fille et son père sarah est
mal à l'aise pour elle ces visites sont
une véritable épreuve débuter dure je
voulais vraiment pas y aller que je
pleurais il faisait un peu peur ce qu'il
était impressionnant mon père moi
j'étais très très sauvage donc de mon
côté c'était compliqué j'avais un rejet
au début
lui ma mère m'a redit bah il était
patient disait que c'était pas grave on
ça le touchait quand même voilà mais il
a su attendre il a su patienter il m'a
forcé à rien du tout et puis c'est venu
progressivement assez lentement mais
petit à petit ça c'est mieux passé puis
j'ai intégré voilà c'était mon père
durant cinq longues années Sarah va
rendre visite à son père en prison
une relation en pointillés qui lui
permet peu à peu de se construire une
figure paternelle
Valérie 3D avec vous faites partie de
l'association en jeu d'enfants qui tente
de faciliter la relation entre les
détenus et leurs proches Sarah explique
qu'elle est allé voir son père pour la
première fois en prison à l'âge de 4 ou
5 ans la première question qui nous
vient quand on l'entend c'est de savoir
si c'est une bonne chose ou une mauvaise
chose d'emmener les enfants au parloir
Arnaud à l'association on part du
principe que c'est important pour qu'on
l'enfant de savoir où se trouve son
parent que soit son père sa mère je
dirais que ce qui compte en fait c'est
pas le fait d'aller dans cet endroit qui
est la prison qui sont fait peur aux
adultes voilà on a une image assez
triste de cet endroit gris les enfants
c'est pas du tout ce qu'ils ont en tête
on leur transmet nos peurs ça ne fait
pas peur aux enfants la prison non moi
j'ai des souvenirs d'adultes me disant
surtout faut pas nommer l'endroit faut
pas dire où est son père il va avoir
peur faire des cauchemars des barreaux
donc on s'aperçoit déjà que l'enfant il
sait très bien parce qu'il a entendu
lors d'un repas de famille ou que Papa
est en prison ils ont une image de la
prison bien sûr avec des barreaux mais
pour eux c'est l'endroit où est leur
père ou et leur mère donc eux ce qu'ils
souhaitent c'est aller le rencontrer peu
importe l'endroit qu'il faut
dédramatiser banaliser la prison pas
banalisé mais dire la réalité de la
chose oui papa il est dans un endroit
qui s'appelle la prison c'est à dire
qu'un juge a décidé qu'il ne pouvait pas
ressortir parce que l'enfant de toute
façon il va ressentir les choses il va
les vivre si à côté de ça il peut pas
poser de questions et si l'adulte en
face ne lui en parle pas voilà il va
rester avec une sensation un peu bizarre
de choses incomprise et ce qu'il va
avoir en tête va peut-être être dire que
la réalité alors on a en tête l'image
des parloirs dans les milieux fermés
dans toutes ces séries américaines
comment ça se passe dans la réalité la
rencontre des enfants avec leurs parents
là-dessus l'administration pénitentiaire
a vraiment avancé depuis une dizaine
d'années ils ont aménagé les pareurs
familiaux les endroits pour les familles
voilà on va amener les jeux on va amener
des livres on amène du mobilier adapté
pour rendre un peu plus gai l'endroit
par contre oui on va toujours passer les
portes on est obligé de donner nos
papiers quand on arrive donc tout ça
c'est expliqué à l'enfant aussi est-ce
que le fait de voir leurs enfants en
prison ça pèse les détenus est-ce que ça
réduit un peu la violence oui c'est
important le maintien des liens
familiaux et pour la vie en détention et
puis pour la réinsertion aussi quoi on
sait très bien qu'un détenu qui a coupé
tous les liens
voilà c'est beaucoup plus difficile à
réinsertion après il nous le disent
c'est une seconde peine quoi j'ai été
oubliée dans les murs j'ai oublié à
l'extérieur aussi quoi
[Musique]
les Zemmour ont fui Paris en hâte à
Miami c'est une nouvelle vie qui
commence pour la famille Michael a 5 ans
quelle école il y a les copains il y a
le motocross il y a le bateau
[Musique]
il y a la piscine il y a les amis il y a
le soleil il y a les palmiers tout est
permis une vie de rêve en apparence car
sous le soleil de Floride tout n'est pas
rose le quotidien du garçon est marqué
par l'alcoolisme de sa mère et le
tempérament violent de son père
[Musique]
après il y avait une tension permanente
qui existait à la maison j'étais jamais
trop pressé de rentrer souvent ou parce
que je voulais pas voir ma mère dans un
état pitoyable ou parce que je voulais
pas avoir mon père en frappé ma mère
ou parce que
je savais que tout et n'importe quoi
pouvait arriver d'une minute alors je le
sentais même si je savais pas pourquoi
mais je sentais que ça allait éclater
ouais
si on monte dans la villa de Miami et la
structure familiale finit par voler en
éclat la mère de Michael est subitement
exclue du temps
elle m'a pas dit en voir on lui a pas je
pense donner le choix de pouvoir me dire
en voir même donc ça ça a été un
arrachement mais pas question pour de
flancher et de décevoir ce père qui
attend beaucoup de lui
l'enfant repousse donc ses limites et
flirtent souvent avec le danger cascade
à moto tir au pistolet tout est bon pour
recueillir la sentiment des gars
il y a que plus tard que je me suis
rendu compte que toutes les choses qu'il
a essayé de me transmettre
ils sont arrivés beaucoup trop à
l'avance
j'ai pas eu le temps de
voir les choses comme un enfant il me
demandait quand même de voir les choses
d'une façon assez accélérée j'aurais
bien voulu vivre ma vie
un rythme plus normal quand j'étais
enfant faire des trucs d'enfants quand
j'étais adolescent faire des trucs
d'adolescents ça j'aurais bien aimé ça
une éducation
[Musique]
à la le pire est à venir
le 8 avril 1983 reste gravée dans la
mémoire de Zem ce soir-là Edgar son père
est assassiné dans la vie la familiale
l'enfant à 11 ans la descente aux enfers
commence
je suis rentré dans la chambre la
moquette avait été retirée donc je
savais que mon père était mort et que ça
avait été fait d'une façon violente
alors pourquoi je savais ça je sais pas
je sais pas alors est-ce que
inconsciemment toute mon enfance j'ai
entendu des choses que j'ai pas voulu me
admettre je sais pas
France pour les funérailles d'egard le
cimetière est noir de monde ils sont des
centaines à venir rendre hommage aux
parents il y a des intimes il y a de la
famille intime et de la famille proche
il y a mais c'est pas un moment de
recueillement c'est un constat public
les photographes et la presse ils se
faisait tout un tout un truc de ça parce
que ça ça
vendait quoi
ça vendait
j'ai ouvert
un magazine de par image un photographe
avait réussi à prendre en photo mon père
à la morgue comme un animal de chasse
qui avait été chassé
je sais pas qui c'était
si dans le clan Zemmour on ne pose pas
de questions personne ne va expliquer à
l'enfant ce qui s'est passé
impossible donc pour Michael de
comprendre les raisons de l'assassinat
de son père
c'était pas un processus de deuil à ce
moment-là il fallait revenir plus tard
pour le faire on a fait la place
de le faire et il y avait trop il se
passait trop de trucs
ils avaient pas le temps de vraiment
s'occuper de moi ou de savoir si
j'allais bien ils m'ont jamais demandé
qu'est-ce que je ressentais à aucun
moment on m'a jamais posé cette question
là qu'est-ce que tu ressens n'a jamais
posé
sans aucun repère
ma tâche à ce qui lui reste de famille
il est pris en charge par son oncle
Gilbert mais le sort s'acharne 3 mois
après la mort de son père Gilbert
Zemmour qui l'a recueilli est abattu au
pied de son domicile parisien c'est la
panique
c'est la panique totale
c'est la panique totale parce que je
pense que je sais à ce moment là que je
suis tout seul et que je vais l'être à
partir de ce moment-là
et j'ai que 11 ans et je sais qu'il faut
que j'y arrive
Michael n'est encore qu'un enfant il a
perdu son père il est sans nouvelles de
sa mère l'enfant va passer deux années
en pension avant de regagner les
États-Unis et perdre totalement pied
[Musique]
je marche Florent vous êtes avocat
finalement quand une personne est jugée
c'est quelque part toute la famille qui
est jugée une sanction qui est
collective alors moi je regrette
beaucoup dans la chaîne pénale notamment
de condamnation nous assise on ne
tiennent pas compte suffisamment de la
place de la famille mais est évident
quand votre père votre mère votre frère
votre sœur votre fils est condamné à 15
ans 20 ans ou à la perpétuité c'est
toute la famille qui ont supporte le
bois parce que vous ne voyez plus les
parents parce qu'il faut les voir au
parloir parce que vous avez perdu le
revenu qui était lié au travail du père
ou de la mer parce qu'on peut payer la
maison parce que vous retrouvez à la rue
parce qu'on est jugé médiatiquement
parce qu'à l'école au moment du doigt
c'est le fils de c'est la fille de bon
c'est la sanction les collective or
cette dimension là la justice pénale
n'en tient pas du tout compte il
faudrait faire quoi pour commencer
la personnalité de la personne que l'on
juge ou pas ou naturellement ou
innocente on devrait tenir compte
beaucoup plus de sa structure familiale
je sais pas de l'âge des parents de
l'âge des enfants de la situation
matrimoniale la situation économique il
s'agit pas de dire que ça devra
influencer sur la culpabilité mais ça
devrait influencer à mon avis sur la
sanction aura actuellement c'est pas le
cas lorsque vous parlez aux enfants des
accusés ce que vous leur dites tout ou
est-ce qu'il y a des choses que qu'on ne
dit pas moi je crois qu'il faut pas le
leurrer les gens lorsque les faits sont
objectivement commis il faut pas les
leurrer mais il faut pas les traumatiser
non plus sachant que de toute manière au
procès d'assise ils seront tout puisque
si le procès public ils une fois qu'ils
ont témoigné pourront rester et même si
le procès à huis clos une fois qu'ils
ont témoigné avec l'autorisation de
cours qui leur sera accordée ils
assisteront à tout mais c'est compliqué
pour les enfants
le message passe bien que on a pu
commettre des choses terribles terribles
que la loi est prime à un moment donné
un pointé non tel pays ça n'empêche pas
qu'on peut aimer ses enfants aimer son
épouse être un bon père un bon mari que
l'un n'empêche pas l'autre et qu'il y a
pas de monstre avec une avec des pieds
une fourche des pieds cornus ou des
cordes sur la tête et les pieds fourchus
voilà ça doit être la bonne expression
et que c'est pas comme ça
[Musique]
les années passent
et signes qu'elle trouvait si
intimidante sa mère estime alors qu'elle
est en âge de comprendre la situation
quand j'ai eu 7 ans en fait elle a
décidé de m'expliquer ce qui se passait
exactement et pourquoi papa n'était pas
tout le temps à la maison elle m'a dit
de venir la voir on s'est assis sur le
canapé et elle m'a dit bah voilà tu sais
que papa n'est pas là n'est pas là
souvent qu'on va le voir je t'ai dit
qu'ils travaillaient sur Paris en fait
alors les phrases exagères je sais plus
je crois qu'elle a pas été lapidaire en
disant directement papa est en prison
elle a amené les choses elle m'a fait
comprendre les choses à aucun moment
elle m'a dit que c'est parce qu'il avait
fait des choses de mal ni parce que
c'était injuste elle m'a juste expliqué
les faits c'était très calme c'était
très serein j'ai encaissé la chose grâce
aux explications rassurantes de sa mère
la fillette apprend également à
dédramatiser l'univers carcéral
pour moi prison également dit qu'on
enferme ça jamais été l'équivalent de ça
alors peut-être parce que on en avait
déjà parlé avant aussi avec ma mère et
que du coup dans mon éducation avait été
intégrée le fait que on n'était pas
forcément en prison parce qu'on était un
criminel parce que pour moi mon père
c'est pas un crime ça a jamais été un
criminel et du coup non c'est pas un mot
c'était pas un mot tabou et c'est pas un
mot qui qui m'a fait peur
une nouvelle étape décisive se dessine
dans la vie de Sarah elle a 10 ans après
avoir passé la moitié de sa vie derrière
les barreaux son père va être libéré une
sortie qui inspire des sentiments
contradictoires à la fillette
j'étais contente bien sûr que mon père
revienne effectivement de d'avoir enfin
cette totale normalité ça j'en étais
contente après appréhension aussi parce
que je savais pas ce que c'était que de
vivre avec son père donc voilà je me
disais est-ce que ça va bien se passer
ou pas
les angoisses de sa race sont d'autant
plus marquées qu'elle a toujours
entretenu une relation fusionnelle avec
sa mère elle redoute donc que cet
équilibre ne soit mis à mal quelque part
j'allais perdre ma relation exclusive
avec ma mère sur le quotidien en même
temps voilà c'était mon père
ça a pas été toujours simple là
honnêtement c'est ça a été parfois un
peu compliqué des fois c'était très bien
puis des fois lui aussi cherchait sa
place enfin pour lui ça devait être
encore bien plus difficile que pour moi
il retrouvait la liberté une fille qui
avait grandi qu'il avait vu que de façon
très épisodique une vie qu'avait
continué quand même malgré tout et c'est
un Charlie Bauer maladroit qui intègre
le foyer familial
les mois puis les années passent les
relations s'ajuste au sein de la famille
mais pour ça il faut composer avec la
personnalité parfois envahissante de son
père ça a pas toujours été facile de de
trouver sa place parce que oui voilà
c'est un charisme énorme
il faut voilà puis il prend oui prenez
beaucoup de place
il avait raison de toute façon il est
très tranché témoins de cette époque
Charlène une amie de Sarah
la jeune femme admet avoir été fortement
intimidée par Charlie Bauer je résume à
vous dire si m'impressionnait parce que
je savais
mais je pense qu'il m'impressionnait
surtout parce que parce que c'était
quelqu'un d'impressionnant
avec ses yeux ses yeux très noirs son
charisme aussi enfin un charisme
vraiment impressionnant et on sentait
aussi que si il avait quelque chose à
vous dire il vous le dirait quoi et que
ça ferait peut-être mal dans son
éducation en tant que père il était
quand même dur et sévère
une sévérité sans jamais de geste ni
rien mais il était quand même il était
pas facile avec moi il avait beaucoup
d'attentes et il était très très dur au
niveau scolaire au niveau de mes
fréquentations j'avais pas le droit de
sortir ce que j'étais une fille aussi il
me le disait clairement et tout ça c'est
vrai que
notamment quand j'étais plus petite mais
copains le voyaient pas ils disaient
tout ça où tu as trop de chance j'ai
trop de chance trop de chance tous les
jours à la maison c'est pas forcément
évident ce qu'il était voilà il était
dans le spectacle aussi tout le temps
avec son charisme voilà tout le monde
était
des fois au quotidien son charisme
c'était pas évident tous les jours quoi
voilà c'était pas toujours évident
est-ce que vous vous avez connu des
enfants de grands bandits grands voyous
oui des affaires qui ont fait la une des
journaux ça on envoie beaucoup c'est pas
change quelque chose le regard que les
gens portent sur eux les enfants que
j'ai accompagné qui ont fait la une des
journaux le procès de leurs parents nous
disent un jour ou l'autre on tombe sur
les journaux on tombe sur Internet là il
y a tout qui nous saute à la figure les
gens nous voient nous reconnaissent dans
la rue on est montré du doigt on paye
pour ce que nos parents ont fait quoi
donc il faut les préserver deux fois
c'est ce que je dis le souvent on pense
aux victimes on oublie aussi que les
victimes je sais pas c'est direct
indirecte c'est aussi les enfants de ces
personnes là quoi et qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour les protéger aussi quoi
Michel Marie parce que vous en avez
côtoyé vous défie sous des filles de
voyous
j'ai connu des enfants de voyous ce sont
des enfants comme les autres qu'est-ce
qui a quelque chose qui vous a frappé
chez eux une différence
c'est un peu au cas par cas moi ceux que
j'ai rencontré parce que les parents
étaient intelligents ont plutôt s'en
sont bien sorti donc je pense qu'on peut
être la pire des crapule et un voyou
terrible et avoir su donner une bonne
éducation à son fils je pense que il
faut dire les choses aux enfants
cachés caché la véritable existence un
véritable activité son métier
même si c'est pas reluisant je pense
qu'il faut pas le cacher
entre sarah et son père la cohabitation
s'apaise peu à peu et le lourd passé de
Charlie Bauer va même devenir une force
pour la jeune femme
[Musique]
Michael a 15 ans lorsqu'il décide de
rejoindre les États-Unis
l'adolescent déracinée rêve de retrouver
une stabilité ces espoirs vont très vite
être réduits à néant
je me suis retrouvé aux États-Unis du
coup avec une réputation parce que du
coup j'avais disparu à partir du moment
où il y a eu l'assassinat donc quand je
suis revenu bon les gens ils ont dit oui
c'est Michael son père
donc je suis retourné à l'école j'ai
retrouvé mes potes d'enfance mais sauf
que eux ils m'ont jamais ils m'ont
jamais retrouvé mes potes d'enfance en
fait
mais votre enfant c'est mon regard est
comme quelqu'un d'autre à partir de ce
moment-là
peine à trouver sa place
[Musique]
journée à traîné dans la rue seul
échappatoire pour l'adolescent la drogue
je faisais ça parce que ça me saoule
j'ai j'avais énormément de douleurs à
l'intérieur de moi je traînais quand
même quelque chose de très douloureux
constamment parce que je portais
l'héritage de ma famille parce que j'ai
porté les assassinats mais de mon père
et de maison parce que je comprenais pas
pourquoi
mon père c'était pas arrêté avant de se
faire tuer pourquoi voilà il y avait il
y avait tellement d'émotions démesurées
à ce moment-là je voulais essayer de
détruire tout ce que j'avais hérité
jeune homme est totalement accro il ne
vit que pour ces quelques heures
quotidiennes où il parvient à échapper à
sa vie je pense que une des raisons pour
laquelle je suis descendu aussi loin
c'est parce que j'ai essayé de m'étendre
parce que peu importe la quantité de
drogue que je pouvais consommer j'avais
toujours mal donc je pense que le but
est
ultime c'était inconsciemment de de me
tuer quoi même si j'avais pas courage le
courage de le faire
Michael survit et très vite l'argent
vient à manquer une solution s'impose
pour financer ses besoins les
cambriolages il a 16 ans la première
fois qu'il pénètre par effraction dans
une villa cossue de Miami
s'en suivent une trentaine de vols à 18
ans il est arrêté
quand je finissais par me faire rater
par la police quelque part j'étais
soulagé j'étais soulagé parce que je
savais que chaque jour je m'étais ma
fille en danger et je savais que ce
rythme de vie là
allait juste continuer à me faire
souffrir mais j'arrivais pas à m'arrêter
Michael Zemmour est condamné à 6 ans de
prison
des humanisé ou la violence et la force
font la loi je pense que c'est ce qui
m'a pesé le plus en prison
c'est la manque d'humanité qui pouvait y
avoir entre certains détenus ouais
c'est
limité de la violence et de la
méchanceté
c'était dur c'était vraiment dur de voir
des
êtres humains
[Musique]
éteint autant que ça quoi et je mange je
voulais pas que ça m'arrive ça ça me
faisait peur
paradoxalement c'est en prison que
Michael Zemmour va se reconstruire
derrière les barreaux il suit une cure
de désintoxication et retrouve une
hygiène de vie et pour occuper les
longues heures passées en cellules le
jeune homme s'évade à l'aide d'un bloc
et d'un crayon je commence à écrire des
poèmes pour des détenus pour leur femme
pour qu'ils viennent les visiter et qui
leur déposent de l'argent donc ça
fonctionnait bien donc on échange bon
j'ai été protégé et en même temps j'ai
été un atout dans la prison pour
beaucoup de gens donc j'avais trouvé une
façon de être
utile
et d'avoir une valeur et donc les choses
qui sont utiles et qui ont une valeur
mais en prison souvent on en prend soin
parce que c'est rare
et Mickaël ne va pas tarder à faire une
découverte qui va changer sa vie à tout
jamais un jour dans une aile isolée du
pénitencier il tombe sur une salle de
musique à l'abandon
[Musique]
j'ai découvert cette salle de musique
par hasard et qui était fermée depuis un
moment et donc ma j'ai négocié avec
avec le maton pour pour pouvoir réouvrir
cette salle et à nouveau répéter mais ça
m'a pas pris très longtemps on a
commencé à répéter deux fois par semaine
des sessions au cours desquelles Michael
improvise des morceaux au milieu des
autres détenus un exercice à risque dans
cet univers
ultra violent ou un rien peut dégénérer
en règlement de compte
pas de coup de couteau ça veut dire
bravo
vraiment je veux des gros balèzes qui
venaient me coûter j'avais des des mecs
qui avaient tué des gens que j'avais
touché
j'avais réussi à toucher des gens que
que je pensais être éteint c'est une
belle récompense
[Musique]
la musique
vont habiter le quotidien du jeune homme
jusqu'à la fin de sa détention Mickaël a
trouvé un sens à sa vie
[Musique]
à la sortie de l'adolescence une
orientation s'impose également elle veut
travailler au contact des jeunes et
c'est dans ce lycée que la principale
adjointe s'est forgé une solide
expérience tout naturellement je me suis
orientée vers l'éducatif et c'est
vraiment ma voix enfin j'en changerai
pas mon but c'est vraiment d'essayer de
de transmettre aux jeunes le fait que
c'est possible qu'il y a pas de fatalité
qui a toujours un doute qui subsiste et
qu'il faut qu'il faut essayer d'aller au
bout de ce qu'on veut faire et qu'on
peut quand on se donne les moyens des
d'arriver à quelque chose on peut on
peut y arriver je pense des convictions
profondément ancrées chez Sarah et pour
cause son père en est l'illustration en
prison Charlie Bauer a passé deux
licences et un doctorat et depuis sa
sortie l'ancien détenu n'a eu de cest de
raconter sa rédemption et ses combats la
figure du banditisme a écrit deux livres
et à enchaîner les conférences dans les
lycées
mon père lui avait le souci justement
d'essayer de transmettre des idées de
d'expliquer aux jeunes que par les
études on peut se construire on peut
s'en sortir un
héritage qui a permis à Sarah de
dépasser les préjugés et de venir en
aide à de nombreux adolescents qui ont
croisé sa route parmi ceux-ci une
fratrie la particulièrement touchée
le frère aîné que j'ai rencontré donc
quand je débutais au lycée professionnel
sortait d'un centre éducatif fermé était
extrêmement violent avait vu son père se
faire assassiner sous ses yeux à l'âge
de 9 ans donc situation très très dure
lui dans l'extrême violence où tout le
monde nous dit que c'était un cas fini
désespéré qui finirait en prison dans 6
mois moi j'ai voulu essayer de croire à
autre chose petit à petit ça a
fonctionné on a pu dialoguer bon c'est
un jeune très intelligent aussi on a pu
mettre en place des choses la super bien
réussi ses études derrière et puis
entre-temps il a appris qu'il était mon
père et alors là ça a fait pour lui ça a
éclairé encore plus de choses et c'est
vrai que maintenant on a vraiment un
lien très très particulier et pas ce que
je lui dis il croit vraiment parce que
il me dit que les propos que je peux
avoir pour lui sont encore bien plus
légitimes et lui font écho
Sarah c'est lentement approprié
l'histoire de son père la jeune femme
tire aujourd'hui une force de caractère
qui lui sert au quotidien dans son
travail
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un risque que
l'enfant lui-même est peur d'aller en
prison plus tard nous le travail qu'on
propose à l'association aux jeux
d'enfants
c'est d'accompagner le parent à mettre
des mots aussi sur ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi il en est arrivé à commettre
cette acte là justement pour que
l'enfant lui ne se lise pas c'est comme
ça dans ma famille mon père a fait ça
ben moi je suis son fils je vais
reproduire voilà que ce soit une
fatalité et nous on va aider le parent à
dire à son enfant voilà pourquoi je suis
là parce que c'est souvent très
compliqué ils ont tendance à mettre
cette question là de côté ou alors voilà
la justice ma puni c'est de sa faute non
non c'est vous le responsable quand on
aide le parent à mettre des mots sur la
réalité et comment faire pour que
l'enfant ne prenne pas ça comme une
injustice
dire justement pourquoi papa ou maman
est en prison
parler de
ce que le parent a fait qu'on ne va pas
à tort en prison voilà il y a une bêtise
de fête souvent on emploie le mot bêtise
mais à côté de ça on met on rajoute
bêtises d'adultes quelque chose de grave
pour que l'enfant ne pense pas que la
bêtise qui peut faire dans la cour de
l'école va l'amener en prison donc en
tout cas ton parent a fait quelque chose
de grave d'interdit comme c'est interdit
maintenant il est puni et ça l'enfant va
le comprendre du coup il va pas se dire
c'est un peu fou quoi mon père il est
privé de liberté pour quelque chose
qu'il a pas fait non il a fait quelque
chose d'interdit donc il est puni comme
c'est grave et ben il est plus libre une
certaine manière il est enfermé donc je
pense qu'en mettant des mots et un
donnant du sens à ce qui s'est passé
on arrive à comprendre et à arrêter les
choses à ne pas être dans la
reproduction
en août 2011 Charlie Bauer meurt d'une
crise cardiaque à l'âge de 68 ans une
disparition précoce qui a bouleversé la
vie de Sarah pour elle le plus important
aujourd'hui est de transmettre à son
fils une image réaliste de son
grand-père
[Musique]
à 24 ans Michael Zemmour est libéré il a
toute sa vie à reconstruire bien décidé
à profiter de sa liberté retrouvée il
revient en France enchaîne les petits
boulots comme ici à deux pas de la Place
Clichy où il retrouve d'anciens
collègues
je suis à l'île de Ré à l'île de Ré
je veux de la musique Michael travail
quelques mois à l'Académie de Billard
une plongée dans l'univers du jeu qu'il
redécouvre avec des yeux d'adultes
c'est ici là derrière le bar je devais
gérer toutes les tables de billard
au bout d'un moment il y a quelques
voyous qui ont entendu dire que voilà
que j'étais le fils d'Edgar et donc ils
ont ils sont venus ils ont commencé un
peu à parler avec moi il parlait avec
moi de sujets différents et parler avec
moi comme en tant qu'homme mais pas en
tant qu'enfant donc il me disait des
choses il me parlait de leur vécu et
c'est glauque c'est glauque c'est hard
c'est dur c'est sombre
un univers sombre dont Michael s'éloigne
très vite pour se consacrer à la musique
une passion qui a entièrement envahi sa
vie ce matin il va parcourir 300 km pour
répéter un moment de travail qu'il
attend toujours avec impatience et
appréhension
les deux premières heures de studio ça
va être
sortir la poubelle quoi tu vois toute
l'énergie un peu nerveuse tout le stress
c'est répétitions c'est l'occasion pour
Mickaël de retrouver ses musiciens ceux
qui sont devenus au fil des années sa
deuxième famille quand je suis avec des
musiciens je suis moins j'ai vraiment
l'impression de pouvoir être moi à part
entière et ça c'est à peu près
j'ai c'est les seuls moments de ma vie
où j'ai l'impression d'être à ma place
[Musique]
cette nouvelle vie dédiée à la musique
Michael Ladoix en partie à Pierre les
deux hommes se croisent par hasard en
2003 une rencontre qui a bouleversé
l'existence de Michael c'est lui qui a
lancé le truc j'ai écouté
ça quoi donc
je lui ai dit tiens il faudrait combien
pour faire la première album il me sort
un chiffre
et il me regarde en ce moment
trouve les musiciens je m'occupe du
reste
cette collaboration n'est un premier
album qui sort en 2004
libérée du poids du passé Michael
Zemmour devient zen le succès est au
rendez-vous pour l'artiste en disant il
a écrit trois albums et vit aujourd'hui
de sa musique
[Musique]
enceinte d'une petite fille Sarah réunit
pour son fils aîné de quatre ans et demi
des éléments de l'histoire de son père
décédé brutalement il y a deux ans
avec internet avec tout ce qu'on peut
trouver moi je veux pas moi je veux
qu'il ait le regard de moi qui était sa
fille et qui suit sa mère sur son
grand-père je veux pas qu'il est juste
l'image des médias ce que des fois elle
est très positive mais elle est même
peut-être trop je veux pas qu'il fasse
de son grand-père un héros je veux pas
non plus qu'il le rejette parce que
prison et tout ça donc pour moi c'est
important que ce soit moi qui lui
explique voilà qui était son grand-père
avec mes mots un héritage que la jeune
femme a minutieusement constitué
donc voilà la petite boîte que je
confectionne petit à petit mais bon là
je pense que je suis pas sûr de mettre
grand-chose de plus dedans que j'ai
faite pour mon fils
donc à l'intérieur des choses toutes
simples il y a des photos il y a ces
livres déjà c'est deux livres qui sont
dédicacés et puis des articles que j'ai
sélectionné moi qui me paraissaient
vraiment voilà bien dire pour qu'ils
comprennent qui était son qui était son
grand-père donc l'article de match le
dernier
on a un article de Libération tous les
objets qui symbolisent vraiment mon père
le bandana rouge qu'il avait toujours
sur lui à la maison et puis c'est
couteau le laïeul que je lui avais
offert
ça montre qui quittait jamais
sa collection de briquets donc je les ai
pas tous pris j'en ai pris j'en ai pris
quelques-uns son boîtier où il mettait
ses cigarettes rouler tout ça c'est pour
mon fils parce que lui il a il l'a connu
il a côtoyé pendant deux ans et demi
Sarah Michael deux adultes qui ont su
chacun à leur manière s'approprier une
réputation et a montré nous rapporter
Sarah attend aujourd'hui son deuxième
enfant la jeune mère de famille épanouie
entend bien continuer sa carrière auprès
des jeunes en leur transmettant les
valeurs qu'elle a reçues
malgré les épreuves traversées Sarah
Bauer est fière de son père de son
histoire et de ses combats
ça m'a permis aussi de me rendre compte
finalement que j'avais de la chance
d'avoir un père fiable le mien même s'il
est très atypique comme papa je pense je
suis contente et je voudrais pas avoir
eu un autre père finalement
[Musique]
après des années de tourment Zem et
désormais apaisé la dernière phase de sa
reconstruction il l'a commencé il y a
quelques mois à peine
je peux aller au cimetière et j'étais
devant la tombe de mon père il y a un
rabbin qui était là comme par hasard il
est venu me voir et puis il m'a demandé
si on voulait faire une une prière pour
les morts et donc on l'a fait et ça a
été un rituel important c'était tout con
c'était tout simple mais je pense que
c'était juste ça j'avais juste besoin de
faire ça il aura donc fallu plus de 30
ans à Zem pour dire adieu à Edgar
Zemmour ce père si encombrant réconcilié
avec son passé il appréhende sereinement
l'avenir
j'aime prépare aujourd'hui la sortie de
son dernier album et veut fonder une
famille
[Musique]